garde à vous
le son des trompettes et une gerbe pour
commémorer le 68e anniversaire de la
libération des camps à 87 ans le dernier
médaillé militaire de Trappes est venu
commémorer la Journée nationale du
souvenir des victimes et des héros de la
déportation
13e
réunions le 8 mai le 11 novembre et
j'étais en particulier
c'est sûr qu'il faut rappeler
les souffrances la lutte de ceux qui ont
participé mais il y a aussi la vigilance
et comme le disait bien le message qu'on
a entendu c'est surtout aujourd'hui avec
toutes les toutes les crises que l'on
traverse à monter les extrémismes je
crois qu'il faut rappeler sans arrêt ce
message de vigilance que l'on a de
où chaque dans ce pays où chacun doit
trouver sa place tel qu'il
lutte contre le révisionnisme le racisme
le souvenir de la déportation semble
peut-être lointain mais le combat de ces
associations est encore bien actuel